[Music]
and get off my lawn News get off my lawn
with your meatloaf submitted by Canadian
ambassador for Joe Mallya oh oh you said
it right this time boo Georgia Malians
you slipped up dude
a sunflower farm has to protect itself
from the public after being overrun by
tourists warning selfies sunflower model
I couldn't have hit that mute I feel
like people look like stampeding through
that [ __ ] and destroying all the
sunflowers like [ __ ] faces people never
take care of sunflowers grow really tall
though yeah but a stampede of people can
Stampede a lot of tall things too okay I
like sunflowers they look like giant
flowers with faces yeah they're really
cute they grow pretty tall - yeah my mom
used to go colony sometimes you gotta
make homemade sunflower seeds out of
that [ __ ] that's cool that reminds me
I'm supposed to buy Isaac sunflower
seeds
damn the Mexican is strong in the same
thing the BBQ ones no no he likes it
without the shell though he just died
disha unsalted in the powder flavor one
no I mean we eat it a lot we stereotype
is like the Mexican construction worker
that has a bag of sunflower seeds that's
always spitting those that stereotype is
a white truckers doing that [ __ ] - and
baseball players maybe it's a la la
stereotype thing you're not from here
Stevie or no our parents used to eat
[ __ ] sunflower seeds mine too out of
here but I learned some flowers he's one
of my white friends from watching sports
I learned information churro when he
would eat sunflower seeds out of his
body but oh yeah yeah these Ventura
all right so this takes place in Canada
it's this place called boggle seeds and
so they been opening their farm for
photographs for people to get to take
selfies and stuff they charge but now
this year just after the second opening
weekend they decided to close their farm
indefinitely because they're calling it
something that they've described it as
like a zombie apocalypse because all
these people they just show up they
don't even care that the staff is so
overwhelmed trying to like sell these
tickets to people and they'll just
ignore the trespassing signs and just
walk in Chinese some of them are Chinese
but a lot of good thing it's not a lot
no like there there's people coming from
all over the world they give it as far
as Dubai inches the people being rude
and warning pics is a great American
melting pot every country United in this
that was us during [ __ ] Grand Canyon
this guy had the wise idea that like you
know everything's like blocked off they
have the railing there but he's like so
so there's like a real stop the story
she's never been there kind of
channeling some you didn't invite me
feelings oh boy America's we were gone
oh I didn't get that at all I felt that
yeah [ __ ] between us girls well our
friendship is strong okay we're just
pointing at the creative I think I felt
that too oh you don't [ __ ] what I was
gonna say okay what was it what she was
gonna say is that you break the rules
you Taurus you freaking go over the
things that you're not supposed to do it
take pictures cuz you're such a rebel he
always wanted to give the exact example
so that you know that these doing here
yeah
railing and the Grand Canyon view so
that you've also let throughout because
that's where that's safe but then he was
like [ __ ] that I want a really epic
pictures and then he walks over the rail
and then it's like [ __ ] windy as [ __ ]
and he's like like so close to the edge
and I'm like Bob dude and then he got
the picture that time with the picture
don't though yes the picture if you take
a picture right Grand Canyon and you see
the rail behind you you know where
you're at you're like oh that's like
that tourist scenic picture he doesn't
look like you're in it when the railings
gone and looks like you're in it and
this is my perspective if you try to do
some landscape photography so when I was
so when I was done I'm gonna climb over
the realm and take a picture say no
don't you dare do that you're such a
[ __ ] travel tourism be like a foot
away that's a pretty important okay
forgot to mention was ding on the edge
of the cliff so Tiger waters I saw his
eyes yeah and you wanted to see the view
and anyways she was so against it I had
a we have to debate back and forth and
finally I was like [ __ ] i'ma go
across there oh you won the debate yes
but there you tell this is how you know
I want your idea is correct for a while
this is how you know when your ideas is
correct when all the other 20 tourists
are behind the rail oh [ __ ] going
okay the tourists were [ __ ] nine
seven thirteen year olds that followed
after I'm like look what you just
started and there were all these little
ass kids know there's a [ __ ] Indian
Couple and then there was that one oh
there's like this one Hispanic and
Korean girl and the Spanish I was
speaking like fluent Korean I was about
to get blown off the [ __ ] cliff go to
that couple oh oh damn how does this
[ __ ] Spanish guy know fluent Korean
but I could just add like being around
back
Wow so you made a group picture go on
nothing yeah everyone took a picture of
this so I had a good idea you know what
Bart is he's like the slow clap guy that
starts it but then it ends up into a big
forest fire somehow like a disaster
happens I just wanted to celebrate she
got a picture - she went over the rail
Oh unbelievable you can't let that out
as well [ __ ]
give me tiger give me do this
yep exactly the whole town's pissed I
made sure I let my position be no farm
here your eyes aren't big enough for the
Grand Canyon I wish my eyes were like
this big you can [ __ ] there's so much
this farm here today they closed it
[ __ ] grand gain tourism board over
I like the Grand Canyon Point a witness
said that or a police officer said that
there were about seven thousand cars and
so they were just causing a lot of them
yeah they're onto something though
they're just they just don't know how to
like do it to where it's effective no
Lobby they do have a parking lots I can
hold I think 300 cars so they were
trying to make it effective it's just
that they got bombarded right because
they're not staffing enough people
they're making Bank are they making Bank
get to pay to go there's some fire from
7,000 people are cars I should be
charging for parking you didn't hire
eight staff members that's not a
dude they rinse it's important parties
what boring part of the world is this at
where people got no offense Canada yeah
what if it's like some flowers to the
horizon been to that I've been to places
like this not worth it
oh yeah I don't know expecting she looks
more interesting in the flowers so
here's like some choice it's cute okay
for the man that are posting up this
sign oh geez galore though he's closed
closed forever and then people are
getting upset like what do you mean it's
closed exactly the way Steve said it was
I feel you that show you there was
people like just cursing at him and just
being super rude
I like killed they're so [ __ ] nasty
about a cute little sunflowers feel it's
great what do you mean we flew the [ __ ]
again here for this [ __ ] people
saying that they went there were from
Dubai from Australia like all over the
world it's candy you got to build some
roller coasters or something didn't
Jesus Christ people don't know what to
do when they're touring your country
yeah they only eat so much poutine right
poutines it was just in Canada I'm like
do you eat the blue tan you're like now
what right and then there's like at all
you're gonna see a Monty I guess maybe I
want to catch a moose real quick the
[ __ ] ketchup chips maple Sarah watch
it watch a hockey game will you do that
a year go to the air Trader Joe's and
see the difference between there Trader
Joe's and our Trader Joe's yeah there's
a Tim Horton rule oh yeah Tim Horton
that's like coffee and doughnuts there
Bacon's different
napkin the Canadian you know it's like
that thick one like the Korean barbecue
Stalin we have it here too by the way
it's not something that I'm like what do
they got man so Canadian bacon is just
bacon class though they're [ __ ] cool
no no I'm talking about like tourism
want to see gangsters apologizing to
each other yeah there's ports in America
that has class I think
you come in so confidently and then end
it with I think he came into the party
[ __ ] confident yeah you'd be a great
politician thank you I am going to make
this country the best place to live and
I think you know that's how I saved my
ass yeah so like if anytime things come
back around like remember you said that
well you know I said I think at the end
and that means like I wasn't too sure
your first four years or like I said I
think yeah just because things are not
great doesn't mean that's not what I was
saying if you look at the clip yeah
what does I think mean it's just I'm
pondering it's not I do it's a guarantee
I swear yeah that's alright that's
that's how you're supposed to speak in
this world yeah that's true I do
actually and that's why you don't get in
trouble I do still not what we hear the
I but I think Oh cuz you're not loud
enough yeah that I can get to you say
the mistake part too loud yeah so in
this case this story was like this I
think so you gotta do it like so I think
the story was like this guy's and they
went down the street I think oh what the
Sailing went down the hallway I think
did they go down the hallway or down the
stairs I think that's how you gotta do
it I'm gonna specially what you guys
that's me all these crazy quiet stiffs
say I think so [ __ ] weird that's that
don't like think for me or something you
think so much can we see more pictures
great transition they did say that there
was this one moment where the these cars
like they had a one of the car door open
and this other car came and drove and
like smash the car - the car door that's
how basic humans are dude they're like
you want to go to a field that has a
[ __ ] ton of flowers [ __ ] yeah hell yeah
it's like in another country though it's
cool let's do it you want to go to a
place that has a big-ass lake oh yeah
let's go see the lake that's my thing
but I don't want to take
anywhere I never want to take a [ __ ]
picture you don't like memories and
stuff looking back yeah I mean it's fine
I like memories but I don't I don't feel
the need to take a picture everywhere I
go I don't know I like I like pictures
cause if you get like oh I remember that
time I remember that time that time how
many times you do that pictures yeah we
go I remember that time I've never once
[ __ ] all the time I scroll through my
own Instagram to remind myself of
memories all the time damn I like it I
don't do that so fun I never looked back
you never look like I don't I look back
all the time I live in the past in tips
yeah
special containers [ __ ] I like you me
what you waiting [ __ ] yeah reminisce I
like it cuz it stores my memory for me
not can you erase it here and I couldn't
watch the YouTube and go that was a
great skip guys oh yeah oh I've been
there for one of those I forget like
half of the [ __ ] that we made that's
basically how you are watching this gate
like ah I forgot we did that the whole
time yeah and I'm like hey can you show
up and let me watch the video actually
[Music]